one of the most important technological
facets of modern life is our mastery of
electricity
flip a switch on the wall and a room is
instantly illuminated it beats the heck
out of trying to make a fire
but the ability to see what's in the
fridge as you forage for a late night
snack is one of the more mundane
conveniences that come from taming
electricity
the reality is breathtakingly
far-ranging from controlling planes in
the sky
causing automobile motors to run to
making it possible to build vital
medical diagnostic equipment so the
simple ability for you to hear my voice
in this course
none of this would be easy without
electricity
and we learn about electricity pretty
early on in school
we learn of benjamin franklin in this
kite experiment we'll learn about
rubbing balloons on our hair and
sticking them to the wall
we learn about how socks stick together
when they come out of the dryer
we learn about a ton of stuff
and of course some of it's wrong
in this course which is about
misconceptions of science that's just
great we've got lots to work with
the sad part is they'll have to pick and
choose
hopefully i'll pick a few that surprise
you so let's get started shall we
so you know the story every child learns
it early on the tale is a dramatic one
with american inventor benjamin franklin
heading out into a thunderstorm with a
kite and a key
he flies his kite into the storm and
wham the kite is struck by lightning and
electricity is discovered
and when you get right down to it that
would be completely fascinating as in
totally amazing there's just one problem
it never happened or at least it didn't
happen that way and maybe it never
happened at all
for instance people already knew about
electricity at its best the franklin
story only showed that lightning was
electricity
in any event here's the classic story
in june of 1752 franklin supposedly
tried his experiment
the first written account of it was
published in the pennsylvania gazette in
october of 1752
and the first what one might call
scientific description didn't occur
until 1767 when british polymath and
writer joseph priestley wrote down
franklin's account of the episode
as was originally published in 1752
franklin supposedly took two light
strips of cedar wood big enough to span
a large silken handkerchief
the silk was chosen because paper would
be subject to getting wet and tearing in
a rainstorm this kite was then tied to a
hemp string and the hem string was tied
to a key
a metal rod was extended from the top of
the kite to attract electricity
that addition was the progenitor for the
idea of a lightning rod which franklin
is credited with inventing
finally a silk ribbon was tied to the
string franklin supposedly stood under
cover keeping himself in the silk ribbon
dry this was important to keep
electricity from conducting through the
silk in into his hand
according to what might be considered
the plausible legend franklin flew the
kite into a thunderclap but before the
rain started he supposedly moved his
hand near the key and a spark jump from
the key to his knuckle further the
little strands on the twine stood up
like the hair on your arm it might if
you take off a fuzzy sweater those
things might have happened
however the largely believed legend is
that the kite was struck by lightning
and a lightning bolt came down the
string jumped off the key and was
collected in a glass and metal
contraption called a leiden jar which
was used at the time to store
electricity
so that's the legend
what's the truth
well nobody is claiming that you can't
fly a kite into a rain cloud but in
order for a story to be true it has to
be true in all particulars
and one real problem is that a kite of
the type that franklin described is
actually very small and hard to imagine
that it would really fly
but maybe it's possible that his
description of a large handkerchief is
just too small maybe it was more like a
woman's shoulder scarf or something like
that so let's give him that one
the problem is what would happen if
lightning actually did strike the kite
we know how to do that nowadays in fact
researchers at the university of florida
do something similar
what they do is shoot a model rocket
into a cloud and the rocket trails a
fine wire behind it
when they shoot the rocket and if they
get lucky a lightning bolt hits the
rocket follows the string or in this
case wire down to the ground level
the bolt vaporizes the wire and an
enormous amount of electricity hits the
ground
so let's imagine what would have
happened if this strike had happened as
the story is told
that amount of electrical energy would
have simply killed franklin in fact a
baltic german physicist by the name of
georg wilhelm rickman died performing
the experiment that franklin is supposed
to have conducted
the lightning jumped to his head and
literally blew his shoes off
so what might really have happened it's
certainly possible that ben franklin
might have electrified his string before
the storm struck but it's beyond belief
that he might have had the lightning
bolt hit his kite he would have been
killed
lightning just doesn't flow down a
string and stop electricity has to flow
from place to place and the lightning
would have tried somehow to get from the
string to the earth and the easiest path
would have been through the silk ribbon
and ultimately ben franklin
so the story is you probably learned it
in school just isn't true
however franklin did advance the
technology of lightning rods which are
the pointy pieces of metal that
lightning prefers to hit say rather than
a house
thus elements of the science in the
story are definitely true
on the other hand not true enough so
don't try to replicate the legendary
story
or if you do
well be sure to have your affairs in
order
i want to talk a little about
electricity in general but this
lightning story reminds me of another
one that's almost always misunderstood
[Music]
i hope that you didn't have to hear the
story of george rickman to believe that
getting hit by lightning wasn't a good
idea
i mean we've heard tales of people who
are hit by lightning and survived but we
hear of those stories because they're
rare normally lightning and humans add
up to a fatality so don't get hit by
lightning maybe that's today's key if
somewhat obvious lesson
how can you avoid getting hit by
lightning well don't go golfing find a
single tree and shelter under that
golf courses are big flat places and
individual trees act a little like
lightning rods bad lightning rods mind
you but lightning rods nonetheless
actually the safest place to ride out a
lightning storm is in the family car
you might have heard that before but you
might not understand why
i can tell you that the reason i was
told when i was a kid that the car was
so safe is totally wrong
i was told it was safe because the car
sat on tires and tires are made of
rubber since rubber is a great insulator
the idea is that any electricity from
the lightning strike couldn't go further
so the electricity couldn't flow through
you and you were therefore safe
it's kind of like when you see a string
of kids standing on insulators and
touching an electric fence
as long as the last person isn't
touching the ground it's safe
when the last person touches the string
of kids and the ground they all feel a
shock
it's also why birds can sit on live
electrical wires without danger
but i'm sad to say none of that is
remotely true in this case
i mean it's true that rubber is an
insulator and it will keep you safe for
reasonable voltages say the 120 volts
that comes out of the wall of your house
or even a few thousand volts
but if the voltage is high enough rubber
loses its ability to insulate
remember that lightning involves
something like 10 000 amperes of current
100 million volts and generates
temperatures in the several thousands of
degrees fahrenheit
if those numbers don't mean anything to
you just nod like you agree because
those numbers are crazy big much much
larger than you encounter in your
day-to-day life
at these voltages and currents the
rubber of the tires conduct electricity
just fine thank you very much
so the idea that tires are what makes
cars safe is simply a wrong one
i guess your next question should be
well are cars actually safe in a
lightning storm and the answer to that
is yes well at least pretty much
the reason is different though
first the only kind of cars that offer
significant protection or metal
automobiles if you happen to own a
corvette forget it it's no help
if you're traveling in a winnebago or
some other sort of fiberglass motorhome
it's not the place to be
the car has to be metal
the reason that cars provide safety is
twofold
first metal is a much better conductor
than say you
if lightning strikes the car the metal
tends to conduct electricity through it
and down into the ground
the second reason is kind of a second
level of misconception meaning it's
partly right but partly overstated even
by scientists
there is a concept in physics called a
faraday cage
this means if you have a metal shape say
a sphere or a cube or whatever and you
put an electrical charge on it
relatively slowly then the charge will
move around so as to be on the outside
of the shape
this is totally a true thing and it
happens
thus in this case if you were inside a
metal sphere and someone put enough
charge on it so they had an electrical
potential of a billion volts on it you'd
be completely safe
the charge would arrange itself on the
outside of a sphere and you could put
your hand on the inside surface and
you'd not even be aware that there was
any charge on the outside
some physics books will tell you that
this is the reason that cars are safe
which is to say that the charge of the
lightning bolt resides on the outside of
the car and it's true to a degree
but that's not the entire story
the reason
is that the lightning strike can occur
in a fraction of a second it takes a
little time for the charges to scurry
around through the middle of the car to
spread on the surface of the car
during that time there could be stray
charges in weird places in the metal
still a metal car is a pretty safe place
to be
between the tendency of charge to reside
on the outside of a conductor and the
additional tendency for metal to conduct
charge into the ground i can tell you
that this is where i'd want to sit if i
was worried about lightning
before we move on to the next topic i'd
like to take some time to recommend a
museum in which you can see all of this
first hand
if you ever get a chance you should go
to the boston museum of science and see
their lightning show it's simply
fantastic
using a van de graaff generator they
make lightning bolts as thick as your
arm right in front of you
these bolts hit a metal cage surrounding
a person and they turn out just fine i
mean it's scary as heck if you don't
know your science
and they end the show using tesla coils
to make electricity flow into the air
and it looks like a tree in winter it's
so totally worth it take your kids
grandkids mom dad grandparents whomever
if they don't think it's amazing they
don't have a curious or adventurous bone
in their body seriously go
[Music]
a question that we haven't talked about
here is just what is electricity what is
voltage charge current and how does it
all work
let's turn our attention to those
questions
so just what is electricity really
electricity is the science of electrical
charges and how they move
now you may have played with circuits as
a kid take a battery a couple of wires
and a light bulb and you got a
flashlight a flashlight is probably the
simplest of circuits
let's see if we can understand some of
the misconceptions associated with basic
circuitry
so there's a battery two wires and a
light bulb that's lit up
now you probably know that if you
disconnect one of the wires the light
bulb doesn't light
we do that in the flashlight by a simple
switch
okay let's talk about some of the
misconceptions i encounter when i teach
this sort of stuff
people often don't have the foggiest
notion of what electricity is a few
think of it as something like a river
some sort of electrical fluid or
something like that
odds are that you're probably not one of
those people but you've likely heard
that electricity is the motion of charge
through a circuit
so maybe your mental image of what's
going on this circuit is this one
a charged battery is full of charge
which you can imagine is having the
battery full of little yellow balls
marked q on them
q is the symbol for charge for
historical reasons way back long before
electricity was understood q stood for
the quantity of electricity
in any event you might think of the
battery as full of charge which then
comes out of the positive side of the
battery one ball after another and flows
through the circuit to the light bulb
and then back to the bottom of the
battery
so that's most people's idea of how
electricity moves
basically the mental image is something
like water and pipes the electricity is
thought to just move like that
but there's a lot wrong with that image
let's take the ideas one at a time to
begin with it's not really right to
think of the battery as a charge holder
if a battery actually had a bunch of
charge it would be more like a static
charge
in static charge you can store the
charge in a place
then when you touch something the charge
moves that's what happens when you get
out of the car on a cold winter's day
you rub some charges off your code or
seat and they get transferred then when
you touch the car door the charges jump
off you and you get a static shock
if that idea were right then when you
reach for a battery the charge in the
battery would jump off and zap you you
get a shock when you picked up a battery
but you don't
now actually in a battery is no net
charge
you probably know that there are two
kinds of charge called positive and
negative and we have ben franklin and
others to thank for those names
and thinking in a more modern and atomic
way we have the nuclei of atoms which
are positive and the nuclei gets their
charge from the protons and the
electrons which are negative
the battery consists of equal numbers of
protons and electrons
since one is positive and one is
negative the battery actually has no net
charge at all
so that's already pretty weird after all
batteries very clearly work
so how do they do that without any net
charge
well it's because of the chemistry
inside batteries
the chemistry pushes the negative
electrons to one side of the battery
what we call the negative side and away
from the other side
since the atomic nuclei can't move
easily and the nuclei are positive once
you slosh a lot of electrons over to the
negative side of the battery that means
there aren't as many over on the
positive side and since we're missing
the negative electrons what remains is
positive
so that's the first message
batteries are electrically neutral
what happens in them is the charges get
separated and only the negative charges
move
the positive ones don't really move all
that much
now it turns out that the
electrochemistry is a fair bit more
complicated than i've said here but
that's a story for another time
basically what happens is that the
charge moves through the circuit and as
the charge moves a chemical reaction
occurs inside the battery that makes the
tendency of the battery to separate
charges weaker and weaker
eventually enough chemical reaction
occurs that there is no remaining
tendency to separate and that's what
happens when we say that a battery is
dead
in our mental image of a battery i just
discussed where the charge comes out of
the positive part of the battery and
moves around the circuit i didn't
identify the charge as positive or
negative in principle the positive side
of the battery can be thought of the
place where positive charges leave the
battery and then zoom around to the
negative side
we have a name for that we call it
electrical current
electrical current is defined to be just
the motion of positive charges and the
direction of electric current is just
the direction of the motion of positive
charges
following that train of logic the
positive charges then flow easily
through the metal and less easily
through the filament of the lamp and the
filament then heats up and glows and
voila we have a light bulb
except of course none of that happens
that's not what's going on inside the
wires in the circuit
we have ben franklin to thank for this
explanation however in his defense i
should note that he did his work on
electricity in the 1750s and 60s
we didn't even know that atoms were a
real thing until the mid-1800s
and it wasn't until 1897 that we
identified the electron and not until 8
1918 or 1919 when we understood some of
the key features of atoms and as late as
the mid to late 1920s when we finally
got a handle on the whole thing
so given the fact that benjamin franklin
imagined positive charges moving in a
current before the united states was
even a country and it's been less than a
century since we've understood adam's
well well i think he did a pretty good
job
what's really going on well first it
turns out that positive particles don't
move in circuits
remember that the positively charged
parts of the battery were the nuclei of
atoms that had somehow lost an electron
the nuclei of atoms are thousands or
tens of thousands times heavier than
electrons the nuclei don't move the
electrons do
electrons leave the negative side of the
battery and then zoom around the circuit
over to the positive side thus the
reality is exactly opposite to what most
people think is happening
so we have two visions on the one hand
we have one in which positive charges
leave the positive terminal of a battery
and go to the negative and the other
vision which is negative charges leaving
the negative terminal of the battery and
heading over to the positive one
is it possible to reconcile those two
visions sure
you just have to remember what positive
and negative numbers mean and also what
changes in those numbers mean
suppose you're interested in your net
financial worth
well you have your savings and your
debts and when you subtract the second
from the first that's your net worth
hopefully that number is positive
now if you want to grow your net worth
there are two ways you can do it
one is to increase your savings but the
second way is to reduce your debt
both ways will increase your worth
similarly moving negative charges away
from the negative terminal of a battery
is entirely equivalent to moving
positive charges away from the positive
terminal
both things will effectively reduce the
amount of positive charge on the top of
the battery and the negative charge on
the bottom
and in a real battery what's really
going on is the electrons leave the
negative side of the battery and zoom
around to the positive side
you might have noticed that i keep
saying the charges zoom around
what do i mean by zoom
well when i teach this course in college
and i ask that question i get lots of
answers
some people will tell me that the
charges move at the speed of light in
the conductor which explains why the
light turns on so quickly as soon as you
flip a switch
other people scoff at that because well
duh nothing moves at the speed of light
but they're certain that the charges
must move quickly their reasoning is the
same the light turning on seems to be
instantaneous
but i have perhaps some shocking news
for you those visions are enormously
wrong
it turns out that electrons moving
through wire have a tough time of it
it's not like they're sprinters running
some hundred yard dash
it's more like intrepid explorers of
yesteryear hacking their way through a
jungle looking for a lost city full of
gold
let's think about what a wire looks like
let's pick copper because it's pretty
common wire material
so a wire is just a bunch of copper
atoms more or less unmoving in space
with some electrons on the outside of
the atoms that can move from atom to
atom pretty freely
those are the electrons that move to
conduct electricity
but when they're made to move by putting
a battery on the circuit they have to
move through that jungle of atoms they
move then bounce into an atom then get
knocked off in some direction move
forward again get deflected again and
and so on
the net outcome is that individual
electrons have a very small net motion
the exact number depends on the size of
the wire and a few other things but the
rough number you can expect to see in a
typical conductor and the kind of wire
used in the household is less than a
tenth of a millimeter per second
now you know how long a millimeter is
it's a very very tiny length and an
electron will take at least 10 seconds
to move that distance
so in a simple flashlight that's about
six inches long the path an electron has
to travel to go from one end of the
battery through the circuit and the
light bulb and then back to the battery
might be 12 inches or 30 centimeters
if an electron is traveling at 0.1
millimeters per second that's 0.01
centimeters per second
thus it would take about 3 000 seconds
or 50 minutes to make that trip
now think about in your house
from just the switch on the wall to the
light overhead and back is probably 32
feet or so that's 10 meters
with a 0.1 millimeter per second speed
of electrons that means 100 000 seconds
or about 28 hours
now you know that flipping the switch on
your overhead lights doesn't have to
occur the day before you need them for
things to work
so it sounds
like i'm telling you something this
can't possibly be true
but it totally is
and that means you need to encounter
another unappreciated truth about
electricity and that is how atoms in the
wire and the atoms in the battery work
together
let's go back to our battery picture the
one with electrons on the bottom of the
battery the lack of electrons on the top
and then the two wires in the light bulb
in this picture we entirely ignored the
wires they were sort of treated like
pipes that would bring water through a
house
but that's an approximation that isn't
valid so what's really going on
well first the wire obviously consists
of atoms with electrons that are
negative and nuclei that are positive
so what happens when the first electron
leaves the battery well it runs into the
first electron it sees in the wire and
pushes it out of the way
then the electron in the wire has to go
somewhere so it pushes the next electron
up the chain
and then that one pushes another and
another and another all the way around
the circuit
through the light bulb and then back to
the battery
there's a pretty good analogy for what's
going on
i'm talking about of course trains
you can see that coming i bet because i
always connect electrons and trains
don't you
okay what happens when you push a train
of a hundred cars that is to say ten
thousand feet long
let's put the engine on the end so it's
pushing the entire string of cars
the engine gets going and even it gets
up to a speed of a hundred feet per
second it will take a hundred seconds or
nearly two minutes to travel that
distance
but what about the first car in the
string obviously it starts moving right
away
even though the engine way back in the
in the back is doing the pushing that
push gets transferred through the chain
of cars to the first car and it gets
moving immediately
it's the same thing with electrons and
circuits the battery pushes the first
electron outside the battery but that
electron pushes the rest all the way up
through the line until electrons start
slowly moving through the light bulb and
causes to heat and glow
pretty neat huh
okay i have one more very cool and
surprising thing about electricity to
tell you and it has to do with the
electricity that your house uses it's
different from the electricity of the
battery in the battery situation the
battery is always pushing electrons out
of the negative side that's what
batteries do
for your house the situation is
different
batteries supply what's called direct
current which means that they push
electrons in one direction only
but houses and basically all commercial
power run on alternating current which
means that the electricity is first
pushed and then pulled over and over
again in the u.s electricity is pushed
and pulled into your house 60 times a
second in europe it's 50 times a second
and everywhere else in the world it's
either the european or the american
standard
thus for the power from the power plant
the situation looks different from a
battery the copper nuclei of atoms and
the wire still don't change location but
the electrons move back and forth in and
out in and out
and they don't move very much remember
that the drift velocity is about a tenth
of a millimeter every second and these
electrons change their direction 60
times a second
that means that these electrons move
less than a millionth of a meter that's
one micron or if you're a machinist
that's 0.04 thousandths of an inch or
0.04 mils that's about a fifth the width
of a piece of spider silk
and that has a very interesting
consequence it means that when you turn
the lights on in your house the
electrons don't actually move through
the house they just sit in place
jiggling back and forth
and that's true even for large factories
for example
in fact imagine the biggest and most
energy consuming factory you can think
of
whatever it is it consumes an enormous
amount of electrical energy to run and
yet no electrical charge ever moves into
or out of the building the electrons
that were in the wire when the wire was
installed has stayed in those wires and
haven't moved boom
mind blown or at least i hope it blew
your mind it blew my mind when i first
realized it
electricity is really fascinating and
how it works is so often misunderstood
it's totally worth your time to read up
on the subject
[Music]
you